this is Cody he runs a custom Trophy and
Plax business doing $1.7 million per
year it's a family business that's been
passed down for four generations but the
business only makes 6.4% profit barely
$100,000 and after taxes it's even less
so if Cody wants to pass this down to
his kids one day they're not going to
inherit a thriving business just a
low-paying job with long hours and a lot
of risk I'm alosi I own acquisition.
comom a portfolio of companies that
generates hundreds of millions a year
and I also sold and built a physical
Products company so I'm very familiar
with some of the problems that Cody's
dealing with my suspicion is that key
things that are going to Catal his
business are fixing his pricing scaling
his advertising and figuring out how to
generate repeat business from his
existing customers and so first I'm
going to dive deep into the business
then we're going to break down all the
tactics that he and you can use to scale
your business what's up how you doing
let's talk about trophies yeah so my
name's Cody Cody schulson I own trophy
Outlet well last year we did about $1.72
million in Revenue mainly trophies and
awards personalization uh about $110,000
in profit 6.4 % net margin um and I'm
third generation owner of the company
we've been in business for almost 40
years so that's amazing so when I saw
his low profit margins I immediately
think is it a per unit thing that he
doesn't have good economics on which
could indicate a pricing issue or he
just need to sell way more volume based
on his fixed cost and so anyways I
needed to dig to find out more so what's
the uh yeah what's the goal the goal is
3.5 million in Revenue I really want to
d double uh Revenue the reason this goal
is so important to me is it's it's a
legacy to me if I can create a business
that's profitable and can sustain itself
that's a fourth generation maybe fifth
generation business so who do you help
so mainly coaches um event organizers as
well as businesses and organizations as
well as gag gift uh purchasers I got
that Vibe yeah okay so how do you help
them uh so we offer free engraving uh
fast shipping everything we do is
personalize to the business or the
individual they go to the website to our
platform purchase you know add the
personalization info the logo things
like that and then we fulfill it if it's
a needs approval anything like that but
most things ship in one to two days
sweet how do you make money how do we
make money all right so um on our
website Direct on our website most of
our products kind of land in that1 $150
price point uh we have products that
range from $4 all the way up to $900 so
it's a wide range uh most popular item
is a$ five and 6ot trophy which kind of
lands about $89 to $130 okay and then
Dash plaques which are like little car
show things that guys collect when they
go to car shows and oh interesting yeah
so it's kind of we sell them for $125 um
we minimum 50 but we sell thousands of
them I've never even heard of that so
how do you get customers trophy Al
started in 1985 you know this is our
40th year and uh we launched our Etsy uh
business in 2019 we did about $70,000
the first year and then in 2013 or 2023
we launched Amazon and did about
$300,000 and then last year we launched
Tik Tock shop and we did about $270,000
in Revenue but 250 of that came in
December alone uh so we had a video go
viral with 20 plus million views that's
awesome uh so went crazy so 250 of that
came in in one month so that was kind of
fun you guys are blowing these up on the
Tik Tock shop and since I'm in charge I
got to be here today to make sure these
all get shipped out if you can keep it
going maybe next week I'll make the
come in and they can take care of it
have a good Sunday and you sold those we
sold those yeah and not quite family
appropriate but yeah no I love that and
you were able to fulfill on the amount
of orders that came in yeah yeah we did
about 13,000 of those so do you have
inact set up like you yeah we produce
everything in house so we engrave C
all ship it so what I found really
interesting about these gifts is they're
very sharable both in that like they're
funny and you could share like a video
about it on social media but also
because whenever you gift you literally
send a product to somebody else and so
I'm trying to think through you know are
there ways that we can harness that or
at least lubricate that process so we
can get more shares more referrals more
return customers across four different
channels uh most of our clients come
through uh online and internal is
through SEO and Facebook ads we just
launched Facebook ads and meta about
October November with an agency yeah and
then Amazon we spend about $7,100 a
month between agency and ads and then
Etsy and then Tik Tok still kind of
figuring that one out a little bit since
it all happened in December but about
$2,000 so far got in ads there so the
channels get super overwhelming because
we're spending so much money on ads and
agencies and what's working what's not
working you know so just getting Clarity
from Alex on that piece alone is super
helpful well how many customers have you
have you sold so far in 2024 uh Direct
on our website and I have this broken
work out per channel in a couple slides
but total visits is about 990,000 visits
to our site about 2500 orders just a
2.8% conversion rate and about 781
products so it's a lot of products is
everything everything made to order yeah
everything so it's not so it's not like
you're carrying a ton of inventory like
you got raw raw materials in raw
materials most of it we bring in from
our vendors kind of as we need it we
don't car a huge huge so when I asked is
it made to order that was an important
question because inventory can be one of
the biggest costs in a business and
especially with somebody that had that
many ex skes I got really worried about
it but because it's made to order then
it's really just like optionality so
then you just look at operational
efficiency of like how difficult it is
to make all these different things and I
bring this just from my own physical
products appearance with Prestige Labs
which is my supplement company you know
you you've got to be looking out you
know 8 weeks 12 weeks sometimes 16 weeks
ahead of time to make your orders and
that can be a huge cash drag on the
business what's been holding you back so
I think it's marketing um fulfillment
wise we proved that in December we can
handle about double fulfillment I mean
with limited complexity so um so I just
need more people to the site more people
buying and we can fulfill it so and also
very product heavy with low margins so
working on the margin piece uh getting
profits up a little bit so do you want
to like sell this company eventually or
like what's the haven't really had any
thoughts of selling but I want to create
a business that is sellable yeah so I
have the option if I want to sell or but
I would love for it to be a fourth
generation business someday all right so
how many locations do you have because
you have brick and mortar correct uh we
have one retail location now uh we have
two locations total uh we closed the
other retail location down it is
production only facility okay so the
other retail location um you know does
maybe $150,000 in Revenue out of that
location so just like walk-in traffic
and whatever yeah Walkin email stuff
does it break even not really okay so
we're kind so you have a manufacturing
facility in one retail yeah which also
does some manufacturing as well yeah is
there any downside to just like
consolidating to the one it's something
that we're actually looking at and going
more e-commerce and kind of cutting the
yeah the retail business the fact that
he has two physical locations is a bit
odd given the nature of retail in 2025
the vast majority you know and it's
continuing to grow as people are doing
online sales and especially with the
amount of customization that he offers
it makes more and more sense for him to
sell to a national base which he's
already doing so these are the issues
what are the metrics you got so numbers
1.72 million in Revenue about 110,000 in
profit 40% gross margin I would have
expected gross margins to be higher for
this business and it varies per product
tons of you know like certain I was like
expecting like you know one like you buy
these trophies and they're like you know
a dollar and you're like there's no like
this is made of rubber you know like
okay so it it varies widely between the
products and platform and stuff like
that but uh yeah net margin about 6.4%
uh LTV 133 and then CAC 1190 LTV to CAC
ratio 11 to1 and that's Blended across
all channels how do you come up with
pricing guessing for the most part or
I'll look at some competitors but um
there's not really good Apples to Apples
comparison necessarily do you do like a
Cost Plus or like yeah so I have massive
spreadsheets of all of our cost you know
things like that factor in labor and
then I just kind of add my margins to it
and you know have slowly been trying to
bring that up over the years yeah when
Alex is pointing out the margins and
they're really low and I agree I just
don't quite know what to do yet and but
it's a problem we've been looking to
solve for quite a while what percentage
of customers are are new versus return I
don't have a percentage for that gut
gut I would say probably just on our
website and internal customers probably
5050 okay because this four-year-old
business so You' think there'd be a
decent amount of return yeah a lot of
our business I mean
$530 in Revenue comes just internal so
emails calls things like that most of
that is re is is repeat business the
fact that he's getting $500,000 per year
in return customers I'm going to be
poking on that to see if there's any
unmissed opportunities there that we can
squeeze the hell out of that and maybe
double triple that if we do it on
purpose rather than on accident do you
have very high fixed costs in this
business not too bad no cuz if you have
half the business comes in from word of
mouth I would expect the margins to be
higher like the net margins think this
is big hypothetical it's like if we got
rid of all of the new customers right
and we just sold the 500 and something
thousand from Return customers that
should be free customer acquisition and
then we should make
money right but looking at this I'd be
like I don't know if we would make money
and real quick for those of you who are
new fixed costs are basically costs that
stay in the business independent of how
much you sell so rent is a fixed cost
some kinds of Labor fixed cost your
internet connections fixed cost these
are things you have to pay every single
month variable costs are cost as a
result of sales so if I sell more
products I have more cost of goods right
I have more maybe labor in in creating
those products the costs basically work
by their name they're fixed or they're
variable yeah our cogs are pretty high I
do think there's a pricing issue yeah
which we'll get too okay but okay this
is good your LTV to cac's pretty strong
yeah it's it's pretty decent and I
learned that a few months ago coming
here the first time so I started
increasing and that has that's not
lifetime Revenue that's lifetime that's
gross profit that's profit yeah okay
yeah interesting so what I'm zering in
on is is there a pricing issue and to
what extent is there one because this is
a great limus test because if you get
free sales which return customers are
free sales it cost you nothing somebody
else tells them about it and then they
come in right you should be the most
profitable on those customers and so if
that that level of volume you're still
not profitable you either have high
fixed costs which I asked him in the
beginning or we might Dingle lingle Ling
have a pricing issue it's 40-year-old
business who was in charge of pricing
that whole time like you took it over
from your old I guess he took it from
his old man so like your third
generation so my yeah my parents ran the
company they didn't have a price
structure they just kind of yeah you
know and on an annual basis do you
review all prices every year y
interesting so about February March of
every year is when our vendors raise
prices so then I adjust accordingly got
it was their margins the same when they
were running it uh much less lower oh
way low like not making money at all so
my mom was running it I remember very
distinctly looking at a product and the
cogs on that were like $50 and we were
selling it for like 45 I mean this does
not work yeah so I immediately raised
prices like you know doubled them almost
and constantly just continually up them
yeah I think I have some ideas there all
right what else you got Channel
breakdown so direct traffic and internal
is our you know biggest um 13 to1 LTB to
CAC ratio Amazon our highest conversion
rate at 99.6% conversion and of course
the the Blended 11 to1 LTV to CAC so
interesting and so you don't have LTV
metrics on Tik Tok no couldn't quite
figure that out yet okay um the easiest
way to do it is just go uh total revenue
divided by total number of customers
okay so you did 262 do you know how many
customers you sold on think about almost
13,000 Michael 262 divided by 13,000
says 262 13 20 Yeah clean okay so 20
bucks that sound about right average
yeah well that's the average order value
right so we we just don't know how many
times they've purchased right which is
one as of this point you know MH so aov
is typically used in e-commerce uh or
retail which is average order value he's
saying that he has a low average order
value on Tik Tok but it's very different
for different customers or on different
channels and so it's valuable to
understand what the aov is by customer
and by Channel now this is a little bit
of data but at the end of the day if you
want to win you got to know your numbers
if we're thinking about the business
zooming all the way out we have the cost
of getting a customer and then we have
what customers are worth and the first
transaction you get is going to be the
average card right the first transaction
but then after that you want repeat
purchases as well and so I'm going to
probably be pruning into like okay how
many people buy again or is it a onetime
purchase and things like that so little
bonus for you so I've been following
your content for quite a while and you
know obviously you have the caves of God
so here's the C goat goat greatest of
all time so I
wish is it a cow is it a cow a oh it's a
it's a goat for a second I thought cuz
it could have been a cat like a calf
like a little baby cow I could have done
that too I didn't think this is great
yeah this is one of our top selling
products actually is it really goat
trophy oh that makes sense that makes
sense it's you trendy well thank you so
much I appreciate it I will put it on my
desk and I will show Ila just remind her
of my calf Excellence yeah so we
actually have a gift for ilila also
which is in the back oh is it is it for
me to give to her so I can get some
husband points you get some husband
points you love this oh she'll love
this this is great she'll love this I
love these These are really good yeah so
you want a double Revenue yep got it
what's this I hear about you wanting to
buy another business yeah so I had a
business reach out to me that's in the
same industry in the St Louis Market
that we're already in so um he's getting
old wants to retire so and what's he
doing in revenue and profit he does
about double what we do about 3 million
in Revenue don't know profits yet or
anything we haven't even got to that
point yet um but he's got a from what I
understand he he does pretty decent on
his margins he does a lot more custom
stuff so which there's a lot higher
margin on some of that stuff the biggest
concern with him is 70% of his Revenue
comes through one customer yeah so
that's a pretty big uh pry buy that
wouldn't buy that M gotcha I would try
and find out if I could who the vendors
were that he has in China for his
connections for his raw materials yeah
so that I could try and use those
vendors yeah that was actually one
resource I thought was well if I could
buy this then it's cheap enough it's
monstrous customer risk and it's
especially if you have somebody retiring
that one customer might be so at
acquisition. comom we have a scorecard
called the value acceleration method
which essentially how can you both
maximize value and then also minimize
risk which ultimately makes a company
more valuable in this one he says
there's two big red flags here first is
you've got keyman risk which is when you
have a small business you got an owner
that's retiring often times they are key
man in the business now they've been
working for however many years and
there's so many things that they're
unconsciously competent of and
unconsciously are doing to keep the the
wheels going and it's often not
documented or at least well documented
so that's a big concern number one but
by far the biggest concern number two is
that 70% of the revenue is coming from
One customer so if that customer leaves
because maybe the guy retires and he has
a relationship with them then I'm so out
right on this deal now the third thing
here is we have to answer the question
why bother right like why are we even
doing this what problem are we solving
now he did did bring up that this guy
has some better connections for raw
materials which can improve his margins
which I do think is valuable but do I
want to buy a business to get a
connection I'll zoom out from the from
back forward which is like what do we
want to be when we grow up basically
this is going to become a media
marketing business that monetizes
through trophies right or you can go the
B2B Wholesale route which is probably
like outbound sales team that's calling
wholesalers and whatnot yeah from what
it sounds like it sounds like you're
better suited for the Ecommerce director
consumer side that's what it sounds like
I don't like currently that's where
we're at yeah CU I think you get more
than double sale currently um and it's
just easier but that just kind of came
naturally it wasn't anything we pursued
necessarily but yeah majority of it's
all e-commerce and okay you might have
one of the simpler plans um that I have
yeah uh yeah which is I I mean simple
doesn't mean bad uh simple as good you
know sometimes you have like 10 things
to do it's better to have three that
move the needle a lot and I think you're
kind of in that situation there's three
big things but I think we'll um we want
you come over here and then we'll we'll
we we'll net it out so Cody is actually
at stage five product ties in the $100
million scaling road map so if you look
at marketing he needs to spend more on
Niche down marketing and so the issue
here is that he's he has two different
avatars and we have to get him to pick
pick and commit the nice thing is that I
can probably tell you what the other
problems he's going to be having at this
level are and what he needs to do to
graduate to get to the next level we
broke down the stages of scaling a
business into 10 steps and we did it
across all eight functions of the
business so product marketing sales
customer service it recruiting finance
and HR and the nice thing is that
businesses behaven patterns and so if
you want to know where you're at and
what you need to do to get the next
level this scaling road map is
absolutely free and it comes
personalized to you so we built this bot
you plug in your business information
and we'll send it right over to you now
if you like the interaction that I'm
having with Cod and you're like man I
would love it if acis.com would take a
look at my business and see if they
could help me kind of move the pieces
around and make it significally more
valuable we run scaling workshops under
our advisory practice throughout the
year and if you want that on the thank
you page you can schedule a call talk to
my team and see if it's a fit otherwise
get the scaling road map it's absolutely
free and enjoy the rest of the video
what percentage of customers are gag
gifts so that's the Amazon Etsy Tik Tok
Tik Tok that's all that so that's like
what's that 4% yeah roughly and that's
kind of been the fastest growing since
2019 that's when we launched that which
is all under a different brand
technically okay um we started a
different brand back thing cuz we're we
don't want the explicit vulgar to be
under trophy outet you know Church moms
and stuff get see I hear you with this
business like fundamentally you just
have it's youve traffic in a conversion
page like and then if you already have
let's call it for right now not a
constraint on manufacturing or anything
like that the three big kind of levers
that I want to go off of is number one
is consolidation which instantly heads
to profit yeah pricing which also
instantly adds to profit absolutely and
then media these are the big ones okay
so from a consolidation perspective we
have the SKS right and then we also have
the brick and mortar
locations and then we kind of have like
model so like in terms of like how I'm
thinking through this so from a SKS
perspective if you're not carrying them
like normally I'd be like we need to
massively cut down on SKS but like if
you're not if you don't have like this
Warehouse full of stuff and it's just
like more options for people to purchase
I don't think we need to like get rid of
anything and a lot of the excuse too
it's the same product just maybe for
football versus baseball or something
you know it's a very similar product
right it's a it's a goat Trophy and you
just put a different plaque on it kind
of thing that doesn't bug me and if you
were like man this it's super hard for
my team to to build all these different
things and I'd be like all right well
then we should we should look at that
but if it it doesn't seem like you're
stressed on the manufacturing side no
but that's where my skill set lies too
as far as operations that's what I'm
good at so the second is the brick and
morner if you have this retail location
and it's basically breaking even or Los
money and that's not even the future of
the business then to me I would say
let's just save our 50,000 a year in
rent and then just add that to the
bottom line right I feel like that would
be a good idea CU that would increase
profit by 50% yeah just like chill
pretty much instantly yeah and also
there's just like the headache of like
it's this thing over here yeah and youve
got and you can probably just take the
couple good people from there bring them
to bring them home right you know yeah
so that feels good so the next one is
model this is arguably the most
important decision that he has to make
if in this entire kind of interaction
with me because this is the strategy or
the vision of the business like what
kind of business do you want to be when
you grow up and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs get stuck in no man's land
and they just can't decide and so if you
think about what the definition of
decide is it actually comes from Latin
which is decader which means to cut off
and which means we have to figure out
what path we're going to cut off by
making a decision but like if you wanted
to have an exit of some kind then the
revenue retention is going to be a
really important thing if he just wants
to make money and grow then it would
probably be faster for him to just the
consumer route and simply Arbitrage
media and make the spread which tons of
people are doing right now and I think
would totally work for him but what
won't work is trying to pursue both
Masters and ultimately serve neither so
in some ways you have two businesses let
alone like if you were like forget about
the third one you're thinking about
buying like you already have two and I'd
rather have one I'm not saying cut the
one that you have it's obviously a
40-year-old business but like I really
have to make that decision and and that
that's actually not a me decision it's a
you decision so if I'll say it the way
that I think Le Lea loves framing
opportunities this way because I always
think about upside and she always thinks
about downside and so it's like what
what problem would you rather solve so
in the gag gift path the problem that
you're going to have to solve is you're
always going to have to find new cheap
forms of media okay so it's going to be
like Tik Tok shop is what it is today
and live shopping and that'll probably
be good for another year or two and then
it's like that'll start to get more
expensive and other people compete and
it's like then you're going to be in in
the next whatever the next game is and
you're just going to have to get really
good at PID ads and creative and
conversion optimization on the site
increasing average order that kind of
stuff the other path is you build either
an outbound sales team so that they can
sell these these kind of B2B offerings
that are you know or B Toc if you want
to consider the fantasy leaks and or
just like a meta just like a simple meta
ad strategy that would lead people to
call the number functionally okay and
then there you're saying cool our goal
is to be your Dy provider for life um
and I think the fact that your
4-year-old business sounds really good
it's like hey we're 4-year-old business
our goal is to be your manufacturer for
life and so of course we're going to do
this one but if you want we'll also give
you 20% off next year um if you make the
order now or I don't know I I I play
around with that but which of the two
paths sounds like the the life you want
to live that's gosh that's tough only
because media for me has always been a a
hurdle not something I'm overly great at
do you like
it okay fair I will do it I'm happy to
do it if it makes money of course you
know okay um but I don't know that I
love it per
se this is a tough one yeah I'm trying
to think what you know cuz you could cuz
like if you wanted to hit 3 million next
year I was like we could do 10 million
next year I would just say we're going
to take all of our resources we're going
to go all in on Tik Tok viral organic
and you're going to deploy everything
into Tik Tok shop and get influencers to
do lives for you showing all these funny
gag gifts cuz like the the trophies are
so built for sharability yeah like and
so that's I mean 20 million views is a
monster video but I'll bet you you could
probably get you probably crack off a
million videos all the time with these
types of these types of we haven't
figured that out yet but you know it all
just I think happened if that was all
you focused on you would be able to
figure out because these are funny right
and I think having like little skit
scenarios uh where people you know walk
in and they see the bosses thing or they
they change their their uh their plate
or you know someone loses and then it
just say like Biggest Loser you know
like that kind like the the negative
versions we still need to make this
decision though hearing you talk like
going to here to 10 million I like that
better even if I have to do like I'll
get used to to videos and content you
know the leagues thing is like that's
like that's the that's the very stable
version of this business and if you did
ultimately want to sell in the future
you being able to go to a potential
buyer and saying like I have 5,000
leagues that buy our trophies from US
every year and leagues on average stay
for 12 years MH you know like guys who
do fantasy or whatever it is it's
like that's that's fairly you know
that's a pretty that's a pretty
reoccurring business you know that's a
that's a that's a pretty good business
yeah um harder to build though and
slower much harder to build right that's
also why it has more value so that's the
so if if between those two paths the
like I would like to just make more
profit now and potentially scale faster
then we can talk about the media version
of this I think that's probably where I
would okay cool you know I chose the Tik
Tock route because of the scalability of
it versus sticking on the the path we're
on yeah it can become a big business but
I look at the competitors that have been
in the business for 40 years and that's
a long road and a long life versus the
scalability that I can then turn around
and put people in place that I don't
have to be there like that's more
appealing to me than just just creating
a big business so first things first is
we're going to consolidate attention so
we're going to shut down losing location
so that should right off the bat be a
plus 50% Improvement to profit yep which
is great Cody cutting down that extra
location is going to cost basically no
Revenue because he's getting so little
foot traffic that I'm not worried about
the loss in sales cuz he's going to more
than make up with that in two ways one
he's going to have the $50,000 a month
cost basically drop straight to the
bottom line and for his business given
the low margins he has that's
significant the second thing is that
he's going to consolidate his attention
so he can take the best people from
there bring them to the you know bring
him to home base you know get rid of the
people that aren't necessarily as good
or as I like to say release to free
agency so they have better opportunities
somewhere else and then this way he can
kind of like make the Dream Team at at
home base and really double down on what
matters and I can't really emphasize
this enough the amount of return you get
on Focus as an entrepreneur is higher
than any resource and fundamentally this
is strategy it's prioritization and that
means that if it's not a priority you
don't do it the second thing pricing so
what I want you to do is I want you to
switch from and you're probably familiar
with this so there's a lot of different
pricing models but you have basically
something called a Cost Plus model you
look at your costs and then you add a
margin in and whatever the problem is is
every business I know that does a cost
plus model doesn't make a lot of money
and so you want to switch to Value based
pricing which is purely based on what
someone's willingness to pay is and that
could be unlimited and it doesn't matter
what your stuff costs cuz why do they
care what it costs right basically like
as your vendors increase their costs to
you in some ways it shouldn't have any
effect on the price of what you sell
because the price of what you sell is
completely divorced of that and based on
what somebody's willing to pay got so in
terms of how we can do this so a which
seem a little bit less scary is I would
consider this to sound crazy but like
monthly like 5% price increases like
just keep going okay and just keep going
that is like path one yeah and the thing
is is that every time you raise the
price by 5% you double your profit or
I'll say 6% if you want to be like hey I
doubled my profit this month then the
next month you can raise by 6% and then
more than double because it's 6% times
6% right so that is that is one way the
other way is that you just start um
immedi split testing kind of like
8020 on your highest sales velocity
items this is simple right this is
simple to do you have to do any thinking
you just add it and that's what it is
this one will probably get you more
profit faster it just takes a little bit
more thought so you'll take those four 4
foot 5 foot 6ot trophies and just start
like just keep bumping the price and
just seeing what conversion rate looks
like what what you're trying to optimize
for is gross profit times unit sold and
so if you think about it's like where's
the sweet spot where I get the most
amount of units sold at the highest
gross profit often times it's it's
higher than you think it is because
we're I think a lot of entrepreneurs get
stuck is like sales velocity goes down
and then they get afraid but the thing
is is that you will usually make more
money before you make less money when
sales velocity drops usually I'm
referencing something called price
elasticity meaning if we make the price
go up how much do the sales go down in
general when you raise a price fewer
people buy but the question is buy how
many so for example if I were to double
the price of something and that might
triple my margins or quadruple my
margins and 25% fewer people buy I
should absolutely do that even though
fewer people ultimately say yes and so
he's in one of these situations where
he's selling barely enough to say
profitable he's selling a decent amount
of volume and so I'm just saying I
wonder if there's a way that we can bump
this price even by 6% would double his
profit that's why I'm testing like how
sensitive is this market now he did
indicate that the customer that he
decided he wasn't going to pursue which
is the the the car show guys the B2B
sales the people who are kind of not the
gag gift thing those people are very
sensitive and so it's like okay if
they're the sensitive ones and we're
going away from them are the ones that
we going towards less sensitive and it
seems like the answer is yes and to me
that's a big profit opportunity in terms
of C kadence for Price tests would you
do it on the site more or do you think
you would be doing it on the phone it'd
be on the site okay yeah because that's
where customers see the pricing even if
they call or anything like that yeah
I'll bet you right now cuz I don't know
how many people like Buy is it a super
price sensitive
Market trophies yeah can especially with
certain avatars like car show guys are
cheap which ones car show guys car show
I'll bet you what's interesting about
this is that your recurring Revenue
business is very price sensitive and
your gag price your gag business is not
is not at all right I mean it makes me
lean more towards the the gag gift side
anyways because it's like we can get
customers for free and we have far more
pricing power CU they're in the moment
they think it's funny whether it's or
it's $12 or $16 like I kind of just want
to buy it yeah you know the difference
between eight8 and 16 is monstrous right
for the business so psych PR test and I
would probably start with uh the gag
okay gifs here and then I'll make three
let me try one 6% on uh boring
side boring trophies at the end of the
day you shouldn't take anyone's advice
including your own you should just take
the customer's advice and the way the
customer gives you advice is by running
a test and just actually seeing will you
buy it or not and the nice thing is if
you raise the price and you go too high
and you ultimately have people you know
sales decrease then you can always lower
it again not a big deal but not testing
your price is the most expensive thing
that you can do in a business from The
Profit that you should be making but
aren't now this is the major part is if
your focus is going to be media and
that's going to be the direction that
you're going in was there an influencer
or something who who made the video that
had the the trophy in it no this is my
oper oh you guys did it and it just
happened crush it got tagged our product
on Tik Tok shop got tagged and we sold
70 to 100 off of that and then we did a
follow-up video and that's the one that
had 16 million views okay so yeah it how
many Tik toks you make in a month uh
right now we're doing about uh one a day
and we're trying to ramp that up to
three a day okay the gifts that he has
the gag gifts the head mofo in charge uh
those types of gag gifts lend themselves
really well to being shared and going
viral and so him doubling down on all
the different permutations of that as
different Hooks and different organic
content that makes complete sense and he
should just do as much of it as you
possibly can and for anyone who's
listening to this is like okay he's
going to go from 1 to three I want to
just break a belief for you you can post
a 100 times a day the platform is
incentivized to distribute your content
to as many people as possible to retain
attention and so there's a lot of
Mythology on all platforms of people who
say don't post more than x times I think
it absolutely just comes down to
equality metric which is how many many
times can you post good stuff but
there's a an Instagram page that's in
Bollywood that posts a hundred times a
day and gets like 9 billion views and so
the thing is is that not the same people
are going to see every post and so right
now when you make a post only one or
two% of your audience likely see it and
so if you make 10 more posts they might
just show to other people in your
audience that aren't the first people
who saw it so the direct site traffic
right now comes predominantly from SEO
so talk me about that do you have an SEO
firm or you good no it's an SEO firm
agency how long youve been working with
though this one about 8 months
traditionally I've only I've always had
pretty good success with SEO okay and we
stopped SEO because the company wasn't
previous company wasn't performing and
we just let it go for several months and
then hired another company and then when
these guys came in and started going
back up again what stops you from like
doing more SEO or rather what stops that
like if if you were to say Hey cuz I
mean when I see you 13 to1 right I'm
like that sounds interesting if you were
to say hey I want you to give me like
three client's worth of focus so that
you can give me three times the
backlinks and three times the Articles
or whatever it is that they're tring out
for you is there anything that's because
if you get 13 to1 it's like we should
spend as much as we possibly can on that
and that's why I started meta is but
it's different though right cuz it's
Interruption based ads versus SEO or
it's intent based do you think you go to
the SEO agency and just say like how do
you Max me out I could absolutely do
that okay I would because it's also like
these things are things that are not
taking your time right right so the SEO
was interesting to me because he had an
Outsource agency that was handling the
vast majority of it so it wasn't
actually a big time drain for him and it
had really good returns and so again
allocational resources think about this
way if you have a machine that you can
put a dollar in and get $13 out what do
you limit your dollars in with you don't
you put as many dollars in as you
possibly can which is why I asked the
question like how do we do 10 times more
of this so this is like media one is SEO
max out and the SEO company wants me to
do Google ads as well is that something
you'd kind of throw into that mix okay
mhm yeah especially like these are both
intent based right yeah like at the very
least you should own your own terms
which is like all your names and der
derivatives of your names like I've I've
rarely seen anyone in any business just
own their own terms and not make money
off of it and so people like why I want
to pay for a click I was going to get
the thing is is like you're not always
going to get the click and so having it
there I'm like you're going to make the
money like just you know what I mean but
then the the the second version of that
is you know Associated terms like the
long key wordss now gag gifts 100% no
one's like hey uh you know your
moon follow the plan uh you know trophy
right or whatever um you're probably not
scroll on Facebook yeah like I'm really
looking for yeah I've been looking for a
goat calf uh
trophy right okay so this is the like if
if we're looking at this these are all
what I would consider like black and
white very low lift almost guaranteed to
make you more money moves almost all of
these will just make you more money this
is 13 to1 this is probably going to be
high return this double the profit this
takes adds $50,000 to the bottom line
the price that's for sure going to
increase on the gag gifts so now we can
talk about the the media side so we're
going to go from 1 to three a
day and I think that you should focus on
Trends and memes cuz this is a gag gift
brand so it's okay for you to just like
be silly and ridiculous and so like
there are so many memes Michael where do
we find our like Tik Tock meme stuff
just hire a 17-year-old um sit there and
scroll yeah yeah and just be like what's
like what's trending right now you know
what I mean like if you're a little bit
on the older side perhaps you're a
millennial right and you have a graying
beard and you're ultimately going to be
taken out to Pastor in the next 5 years
right and put to rest um as I am you
have to get people who are younger than
you who are in you know in the game of
social media who know what's hot right
now and can make contextually relevant
or native media that ultimately gets way
more shares way more views and then
ultimately more conversion plus 1,000
Aura to Cody
so what's interesting is that a lot of
these um Tik Tok ones also do well on
Instagram so you could repurpose there
do you do you post on Instagram yeah
okay yeah started yeah at least you're
getting you you'll get a double you know
you get double usage on that but yeah
Tik Tok is like the perfect platform for
you for thei GI like it makes complete
sense to me they did 250,000 in a month
and so when I the reason I said the 10
million is like okay well that happened
on accident let's do it on purpose and
if you can do 250 a month just from that
it's like well there's 3 million yeah I
think you getting really ridiculous with
the volume will get you a lot better and
I think this is one of those things that
you should live close to okay like you
like these things are all things that
you can do probably the week you get
back you know what I mean this one is
going to be this is like the the big
commitment of what's the bet we're
making the bet we're making is that
mastering Tik Tok live selling Etc is
going to be the way it's definitely a
new skill it's a little intimidating uh
to know like okay this is where 80% of
my time is going to go now for a new
task that I've never done but very
Innovative which I love Innovation I
love thinking about like oh hey how can
we be different than the industry and
this is definitely different now the
second part of kind of like Tik Tok
Mastery is going to be um influencers
okay and so what's nice with Tik Tok
shop is that your stuff is automatically
to be listed there and other people can
uh make videos for it and you're in the
price point that's perfect for Tik Tok
shop like 20 30 50 like it crushes for
that stuff and it's it's such easy
videos for people to make right and that
lines up with what Tik Tok has been
telling us too wait have you been
reaching out to them or we have an
account rep now oh cool great well I
guess you did 250 so yeah but yeah
Affiliates they said hit Affiliates hard
T and I mean fundamentally like these
are basically onetime work mhm this is
the only ongoing work that you do Trends
and memes and I'd be posting one to
three times a day there repurpose on on
IG right that's that's just free traffic
and then the influencers will also kind
of this will it'll be like a loop here
so it's like they'll do something
something that works well and then that
will feed like it'll just be this nice
Loop where they're also creating content
for you okay real quick this type of
content I've gotten a ton of positive
feedback on and so I'm going to continue
to make it but what I need your help on
is helping it distribute because this
isn't wide algorithm stuff a lot of
people aren't going to see it because
it's narrower and it is for business
owners so if you know a business owner
or you have kids and you want them to
learn business where if people were
business interested it would mean the
world to me and my team who put so many
hours into making this stuff for for you
it would just mean the world if you send
it to them it would mean a lot and then
I'll put I'm going to put number seven
on here because I think this is worth
it the Tik Tok ads which you said you
just started basically the the process
is going to look like this you make the
ad right or sorry you make the content
you're making content
right you're making Tik Tok content that
Tik Tok content you know 10% go viral
whatever and then 90%
flop right then
this you put ad money behind it you send
this to influencers and say make stuff
like this because this is what's
converting and then they'll make
versions of this that'll also inform
your
content which you'll then try to make
iterations of what they're doing and so
like you're kind of your Source like
you're starting here's the Tik Tok
content some does well great push ads
behind it by the way guys here's the
ones that are working well they make
stuff you can take theirs push money
behind it as well and model it and make
for permutations of it gotcha and so for
this stuff I would be kind of hook
Centric meaning for well for most short
for platforms like the hook is
everything and once you have a winning
hook I would like
reuse reuse it over and over again the
reason I'm recommending he doubled down
on Tik Tok is you want to go where the
fish are right you want to go where
where the getting is good and so right
now Tik Tok shop is crushing it it's
blowing up lots of people are doing very
very well on the platform and he already
has seen some success and and so as soon
as I get that little inkling of success
there's that little blood in the water
that's when I want to just like go go
ham on it so one is how do we increase
volume secondarily how do we increase
quality of output basically once we do
these easy fixes this is really the
long-term strategy that he needs to get
really good at is that he's got to get
really good at media you actually have a
really simple one the nice thing is that
I have a lot of confidence in your like
there's there's basically no like I'm
not really sure like site price test
could easily like 2x profit like on its
own because the are so slim right now
right uh 6X this is a 2x on profit for
sure SEO max out right now it's 50% of
Revenue is coming from that so it's like
maybe we get a 50% Boost from them doing
a better job on it PPC will just get you
good returns this might give you like a
10 to 20% boost so I don't think going
to be huge but it's like it's free and
it's a onetime setup so it's not hard to
do Tik tok's going to be the big lever
of like how do we go from 1 million to
10 million it's like if you if you did
nothing else but just say like a year
from now if all we did was Master Tik
Tok and Tik Tok shopping MH we would win
like if you did nothing this is just
going to take all of your existing
business and make it more profitable so
that you can take all of this cash and
and float into here but actually fairly
straightforward that's a good thing
that's a good thing rather than like we
have to bet the farm on something which
sometimes has to happen yeah that's
awesome way simpler than I was thinking
so oh good yeah dud just do more of what
works right and the fact that you have
such low margins excites me because when
you make five or 10% improvements you
double or triple profit right and the
fact that you haven't like that there
was no pricing um discipline like
there's no there's no like process to
pricing besides like we'll just keep
raising it when our cost go up usually
there's just like when I see a business
like that there's like massive unlocks
like I'm saying 6% on boring trophies
but like you might be able to push 25
yeah and that 4X is 5X is profit right
whenever I see a business that's
mispriced or extremely mispriced I get
really excited because I know it's one
of the lowest operational drag moves
that you can do functionally everything
else you have to do in a business you
got to do something with pricing you
literally change a number or you say a
different word at the end of a phone
call like it's that easy to change but
it has such a dramatic impact on how
profitable a business is and what's
crazy about that is that entrepreneurs
tend to be the most afraid of pricing
changes so it's all between your ears
and psychology and fear Just Having the
courage to just say a bigger number the
fear is that you're somehow going to
lose your business you just if it
doesn't work you just lower it back
again not a big deal but this could
change his life and so I'm very
interested to find out more there what's
the offer that you have in the
Box usually it's a little code that says
like 10% or something to order here
order again why don't you give something
much better than that okay so we have to
come up with a really compelling offer
to get people who are buying the nice
thing the important thing is are you
doing fulfillment for Amazon sales uh we
have some FBA but most of it's fbm so
we're fulfilling most of it okay great
so you're fulfilling most of it that's
wonderful okay so and Etsy same thing
Etsy fill everything yeah great okay so
that means that we can put something in
the Box to be really compelling to get
them to to buy something so if now
Amazon and Etsy the purchasers who are
buying there are they more bread and
butter people or are they more gag
people I would say more gag more gag
okay because they're more like funny
death signs funny saying stuff like that
or jok I would put a bugo offer in or a
so buy one get one to two free okay and
then just fix the pricing of the one so
that it makes sense I would basically
have this little thing here so that
would be the headline on the top of my
little my little my little doad yeah you
got your QR code and then I would have
my top one two and three gag gifts okay
because they just bought one so it's
like let me tell you the other gag gifts
that people buy the most of gotcha and I
would put that into every one of the
boxes okay and the framework that I'm
talking to him about right now which is
you know what we're going to do buy 1
get two free buy 1 get three free like
what are we going to do that actually is
a little a little a little Easter egg
for what's coming out in my next book
what do you how big is your email list
for trophy side yeah I think we have
like 10,000 contacts what do you do for
long-term
nurture not much okay well guess what we
just found ourselves another couple
hundred grand so let me tell you a stat
that'll blow your mind most mature
e-commerce businesses get between 30 30
and 50% of revenue from email
W we're missing out a lot yeah on that
so there's probably like 1 and a half
million sitting there yeah and that's
all profit because there's no ad spent
right most e-commerce businesses
basically Break Even or lose money on
spending ads to get customers and they
make it up with their email followup
gotcha we just found a big bag of money
how about that so this was a late nugget
but I'm glad we found it I assumed
because anybody who's in e-commerce or
at least if you're in e-commerce you're
in physical products or retail email
marketing is just massive and the
difference between small companies and
big companies is often times just what
percentage of customers are return
customers and one of the primary
vehicles for doing that is email and SMS
and so he's not doing really any at all
and so this was just a massive profit
opportunity because he's getting all
these customers in the door and then
just never talking to them again and so
if you're a business owner right now and
you have this big list of customers and
you haven't like emailed them in a while
it's the closest thing to free money you
just send the email out with some sort
of offer and you can get money
immediately for basically no cost
because you already incurred the cost
now the structure that I talk about with
emails is that obviously you can't do
that forever because then you just
fatigue the list and people would be
like well I don't want to list to this
thing all this guy does is try and Hawk
stuff I like to try and have some sort
of value if possible now value can be
described in different ways if you have
gag gifts then it's probably going to be
in the form of entertainment more than
is education right like people are going
to like oh let me let me six ways to use
trophies like I don't know if I'm really
into that but if if I see funny versions
and maybe even emailing some of his
content that's that really does well
might be a great strategy for him to uh
get people to continue to click and
basically reinforce that Loop so that
they want to open it because at the end
of the day people buy newspapers because
they want to feel educated but what they
read is they flip to the back and often
read the Funnies and so it's like how
can we take that old school human
behavior from an old platform and how
can we mirror it on a newer platform so
eight was our offer which we added in
yeah
nine it's going to be email
followup okay there's going to be two
different types of email that you're
need to do so number one is going to be
flows so these are based on user
Behavior so when someone visits a
specific product they should get like a
five email sequence of being like hey
saw that you were looking at the goat
whatever right and that should just that
should happen for anybody who opander
does a twostep or abandon cards right do
you have a Bandon card we do have okay
good the other piece is we need the
long-term nurture all right so what I'd
recommend is three times per
week it feels like a lot for trophies
cuz trophy is a less frequent purchase
the gag I feel like is a it's like if
you buy one gag gift you'd be willing to
like buy them for many people because
you just think they're funny they are
separate Brands though correct yeah
technically kind of sep because you have
like okay so I would so this I'm I'm
cool with on the gag gift side okay
because right now you're not making any
return sales anyways right so you might
as well get we don't really have an
email list for the gag side because it's
all through Amazon Tik Tok does Tik Tok
not give you a email so I think we'll go
one time a
week and we not worry about the gag gift
okay I think just one time a week of and
if if your basically domain score your
domain Health your domain Authority
stays healthy and your open rate stay
okay you click the rate stay okay I
would increase frequency okay so you
start with one a week and you're
probably thinking okay what am I going
to what am I going to email them about
right right so when you have customer
stories cool trophies cuz I'm sure
there's every week there's like one
trophy or something that's just like
interesting that you guys have right
probably stuff about recognition status
and cheapest compensation so I think if
I were to if I if I owned your company
right so I'd be like okay are we in the
trophy business no trophy is what we
sell right but it's really just the
vehicle for giving people recognition
status and compensation right right and
so my the things that I would email
would probably be about how you could
either give your team a pay raise or you
could give them a trophy and believe it
or not here's this research the trophy
is actually even more meaningful so they
like it more and you like it more as a
business owner right so it' be that kind
of stuff that I'd be you only have to
write 52 it's not that many EMS right
you could literally probably do it in
like a day and a half or two days so
keep it low in the beginning just to
like get a feel for it see how like the
first couple emils are going to shake
out because you're going to have a super
responsive list and we want to keep
these all
text all text okay yeah all text I would
say link to the image because then
curiosity is going to drive the click
okay and also image based tend to get
lower uh deliverability rates than like
full text one and when people opt in or
S when people purchase or opt in they
abandoned cart the first one I would
have is um reply back for funniest
trophy of all time and so as soon as
someone Ops it's a double optin so to
increase your deliverability right and
so they'll they'll reply back and then
it's an automation you have to do and
then you'll s them the link for the for
the clickable picture and they'll be
like this is ridiculous and then
underneath of that so when you have the
when you have a clickable link you want
it to take them you want to have it take
them to a page it looks like this
whatever uh and then here you have bye
so like you can have the funniest thing
but it's also uh CTA to get someone to
buy something gotcha one
through 5+ n y are all like bread and
butter do these zero thought y so in
terms of order here all right so this is
number one cuz this is just going to
give you time back
first this is probably
second is it the same agency that does
this and this yeah okay so that's for
both of these that's one
call this is
fourth
[Applause]
fifth six put the email follow up in
place cuz we're basically going to
optimize other other things and then
we'll basically follow up with
everyone and then this is going to be
7th
eth awesome
cool yeah super cool well I think we
found um a few doubles yeah in the
business absolutely I love it feel all
right yeah I feel really good appreciate
it than yeah you bet man this is awesome
going be great this is much cleaner and
simpler than I thought oh good good I
just got done filming with Alex I'm
super excited after this I mean to have
a 9-point bullet point of here's your
Tactical what to do to grow 2x 5x 10x
it's pretty cool so whether you have a
trophy company or not all of the
fundamentals that we're walking through
here is one we're consolidating costs
because there wasn't a strategic
advantage to having a larger footprint
number two is that we're running pricing
tests regularly so that we can optimize
how much money we get per customer and
see how much how much higher we can
drive it especially with older
businesses they often don't change the
prices as frequently enough and
especially with the amount of inflations
that's happened over the last 3 4 years
if you haven't really adjusted prices in
a big way like 50% plus then you're
making significantly less money the next
one is doubling down to what works so in
two senses one is he had good Returns on
SEO but also we know that his organic
with Tik Tok is working so I want to
double down on those things but if you
look at how these things are ordered so
I tend to order them using ice which is
impact confidence ease so how big of a
difference is it going to make How
likely is it to occur and how hard is it
and so if you have something that's
really likely big impact and easy you
start with those first and then you just
work your way down and number four and
this is a big one we make sales to get
customers we don't get customers to make
sales and so the point of the first
transaction that I'd like to shift
Cody's perspective on or anybody's
perspective on is you get the gag gift
sale but then you do everything else to
turn it into a lifelong or at least
repeat customer and so we're doing this
through multiple paths one is that we're
creating the offer to get them to come
back so we can own the data on top of
that then we have the remarketing in
place that's going to happen in terms of
email followup on top of that we could
just have remarketing across all social
media for anyone who hits his site each
of these things have one clear intention
which is how do we get somebody to buy
again so if you like this video you're
going to love this video I did with
Raymond who's a multilocation
chiropractor I break down tons of stuff
that applies to many many businesses
click go watch enjoy